the Shrike is by far the most metal of
birds just look at it
give me some metal guys the Shrike is so
awesome in metal because thank you the
Shrike is so awesomely metal because it
has to be
it may look like a chickadee but it has
the blood list of an eagle that kills
lizards mice and other birds with texts
of the skull and neck
but it doesn't have the powerful talons
of an eagle so it can't hold on to its
prey and rip it up at the same time so
the Shrike picks up victims and impales
them on the nearest spiky object
this could be a thorn like you see here
or garden fork or the most metal all
barbed wire with the prey immobilized
the bird can tear through flesh using
its sharp beak even more sinister the
Shrike will build up collections of
impale victims the bird will kill even
if it isn't hungry then returned to
shish kebob prayed weeks later when its
tummy is empty so metal all right